[Musique]
c'est une décision de justice qui était
particulièrement attendu près de six
mois après la mort de briony taylor
le jury du kentucky a décidé d'inculper
seulement un des trois policiers
impliqués dans son décès un choix
particulièrement clément puisque bret
hankinson le seul agent qui sera donc
visée par un procès ne lesquin
directement pour mise en danger de la
vie d'autrui
une décision qui a provoqué plusieurs
rassemblements partout dans le pays
le décès de cette infirmière afro
américaine abattue par huit balles lors
d'une opération anti drogue qui s'était
finalement avérée infructueuse est
devenu un des symboles des luttes
antiracistes aux états unis pour
l'avocat de la famille le jugement rendu
est scandaleux le grand jury du comté de
jefferson inculpé l'ancien officier bret
and qu'il sonne avec trois chefs
d'accusation pour mise en danger
injustifiée au premier degré pour des
balles qui sont entrés dans d'autres
appartements mais rien pour le meurtre
de bris au natel or elle c'est
scandaleux et offensants si le
comportement de brett and kingson
constituait une mise en danger
injustifiée de personnes dans les
appartements voisins
alors il aurait dû en être de même pour
l'appartement de briounas taylor en fait
il aurait dû être considéré comme un
meurtre gratuit
peu après cette inculpation plusieurs
dizaines de manifestations spontanées
ont eu lieu notamment à new york boston
ou encore philadelphie à louiseville là
où réside et brianna taylor
des violences ont émaillé le cortège
deux agents de police ont été blessés
par balles et un suspect a été
interpellé pour le procureur général du
kentucky
daniel cameron la justice a correctement
effectué son travail
je sais que tout le monde ne sera pas
satisfait des chefs d'accusation que
nous avons présentés aujourd'hui mon
équipe a entrepris d'enquêter sur les
circonstances de la mort de mademoiselle
taylor nous l'avons fait avec un
objectif unique en tête la recherche de
la vérité si nous agissons simplement
sur la base de l'émotion ou de
l'indignation
il n'y a pas de justice la justice de la
foule n'est pas la justice
la justice par la violence n'est pas la
justice elle devient simplement une
vengeance et dans notre système
la justice pénale n'est pas la quête de
la vengeance c'est la quête de la vérité
des preuves et des faits et
l'utilisation de cette vérité dans
l'application équitable de nos lois une
décision de justice qui a également fait
réagir la classe politique américaine le
candidat démocrate à la présidentielle
joe biden a appelé au calme tout en
disant comprendre la frustration des
manifestants de haltes rome de son côté
a salué le travail effectué par le
procureur du kentucky et annonce prié
pour les deux policiers touchés par
balles à louiseville